la réunion était déjà inscrite à
l'agenda les ministres européens des
affaires étrangères avait rendez vous ce
lundi à bruxelles pour discuter du
conflit qui oppose kiev à moscou
je ne pense pas qu'il faille dramatiser
dans la mesure où les négociations se
poursuivent et c'est bien le cas je ne
pense pas que nous devions laisser
l'ukraine t partir
le secrétaire d'état américain blinken
nous expliquera les raisons de cette
année
car quelques heures avant la réunion la
donne a changé les etats-unis ont
annoncé l'évacuation des familles de
leurs diplomates en ukraine ils
redoutent de voir moscou y imposer un
dirigeant prorusse
le royaume uni à l'origine de ces
accusations a rapidement suivi le
mouvement pour le premier ministre boris
johnson une invasion de l'ukraine par la
russie serait à la fois désastreuse
douloureuse violente et sanglante de son
côté l'union européenne préfèrent
renforcer son soutien financier pour
aider kiev à se défendre et la france
conseille à ses ressortissants de
reporter leurs voyages non essentiels
en parallèle les pays de l'otan ont
envoyé des renforts militaires prêts à
intervenir en cas d' attaque car des
milliers de soldats russes sont postés
depuis plusieurs semaines à la frontière
avec l'ukraine une situation qui n'est
pas sans rappeler celle de 2014 lorsque
moscou s'étaient emparés de la péninsule
de crimée